hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're back on for tonight
and today we're gonna be talking about
the heavy shotgun and in specific we're
gonna be talking about a guide on how to
use this weapon most effectively so
let's get started so for anyone that
doesn't know the heavy shotgun has just
been added today it is the newest gun
added to fort night battle royale and my
god is this gun just a little bit
game-breaking it is an epic and legend
to your weapon meaning it is purple and
gold and I believe it can only be found
in chess I have not found I've only
found these in chess and on dead bodies
that I've killed I have yet to find it
on the floor but that could just be me
being unlucky I'm not entirely sure but
like usual let's go over the damage
numbers and some strategies when to use
it as well some general tips and my
thoughts by comparing it with similar
weapons like in this case the pump and
attack so the heavy shotgun just like
other shotguns has some weird ranges on
damage numbers everyone really knows
that when you use the attack or the pump
you could do like 60 damage then you
just do like 6 or like 8 it doesn't
really make much sense but most commonly
I've been hitting people for 40 to 70
damage sometimes even 114 to 144 it all
depends on the range and whether or not
it's a headshot or not for the stats the
epic or purple version has 73.5 damage a
1 second fire rate 7 magazine size and a
5.9 reload speed for the legendary
version has 77 damage a 1 second reload
speed a 7 mag size and a 5.6 reload
speed so the only difference between
purple and legendary is that the
legendary has 0.3 faster reload speed
and 3 more damage so nothing too
incredible compared to the tactical
shotgun the epic version of it in this
case the purple one has a point 5 faster
fire rate making it a little bit more
deadly but that but that's also if you
have the purple version of the tax
shotgun in terms of comparing it judging
from the community's perspective on this
weapon its a mix between attack and a
pump it seems to have slightly less
range than the pump but also shoots a
little bit faster and does more damage
than the tactical shotgun making this
weapon still very deadly
the only issue people are worried about
is the double heavy shotgun potential I
was not lucky enough to get too heavy
shotguns but dakotas another popular
youtuber that you guys probably already
know by now he managed to get two
shotguns on stream and somebody took a
clip of it which I'll show in the
background this looks just like the
double pump though before it was nerf or
you could switch between pump to pump
and now you can switch between heavy
shotgun too heavy
gun super quickly and a lot of other
people are starting to notice this as
well in its defense though the rarities
for this weapon are very high like I
said being purple and gold and it's very
rare to get to double heavy shotguns
since it's so rare it seems like it's
going to be more of an issue in the
endgame instead of the pump which was
mostly an issue in the beginning of the
game since pumps can be green and grey
but the fact that it still exists is a
bad idea
so let me know what you guys think about
this double heavy shotgun meta if this
is even a thing if we should be worried
about it if this is a very big issue
anything that you guys have on that I'd
love to know in the comments below
sadly though there really isn't much
strategies for this weapon since this is
basically another shotgun you want to
use it as such you can't be as far in
terms of range compared to a pump but
you can still have some decent range
nonetheless you can't be very aggressive
with this gun and clearly since it is a
shotgun but you don't have to be up in
their face the whole time to get some
decent damage you can pair this up with
an assault rifle SMG or another shotgun
if you like and you can initiate the
fight with the heavy shotgun chip off a
lot of their help and then finish them
with a quick shotgun blast or a spray of
bullets whether that be with the SMG or
the assault rifle I'm going over my
thoughts and opinions though on this gun
I feel like it feels like it's more in
addition than a replacement the pump
still does more damage and has more
range yes it does beat out the tactical
shotgun in most aspects but like Lee
stated the heavy shotgun is purple and
gold while the TAC is green blue and
purple meaning the heavy shotguns won't
barely show up I've been playing for
about three straight hours and I've only
got the heavy shotgun once or twice
which is the reason why most of the
gameplay in the background isn't really
heavy shotgun oriented since once again
this only drops from chess and this is
incredibly hard to find because if it's
purple and gold rarity I might just be
unlucky I'm not entirely sure again but
these are my thoughts on the heavy
shotgun regarding its damage its range
and anything comparing it let me know
what you guys think about the heavy
shotgun in the comments below whether
you found it or found it in like floor
loot or something like that I'd love to
know any of your thoughts below but yeah
that's going to be the end of the video
today guys like I said I just feel that
the heavy shotgun is more of an addition
more than a replacement it's definitely
not going to replace the pump in any
aspect and it's definitely not going to
be replacing the tactical shotgun it's
more of that next step up think of like
the TAC shotgun but now instead of
getting now there's like a gold
variation it will just say as an example
so it's kind of like moving up in a tier
list it's not going to be going anywhere
it will still be useful but it probably
won't replace any of the current
shotguns and the game is seeing as those
are still very powerful although I do
have to admit though the heavy shotgun
is a lot of fun to use it's pretty beefy
pretty tanky does some decent damage for
how much range it has once again it's
not an incredible amount but it still
some decent range buzz that but as I
previously stated that's going to be the
end of the video like if you did enjoy
that has helped me out subscriber if you
knew I got a tons of guides coming out
for for night making people better
players guides on new weapons when they
release and other stuff like that that
I'm cooking up so if you guys do enjoy
that then definitely stick around I'll
be posting more of this stuff in the
future my two most recent videos are
gonna be on screen if you guys do want
to check that out and with that guys
hope you have a great rest of your day
and peace out